alors la catastrophe écologique qui
menace le littoral est une réalité à
l'intérieur des terres le marais
poitevin énormément souffert pendant la
tempête lundi soir les conséquences
économiques seront lourdes le reportage
de philippe mal essayé de laurent pelly
c'est un paysage de désolation un
véritable champ de ruines plus de 80%
des peupliers du marais poitevin sont
détruits arracher la mine et ses 5500
hectares aujourd'hui complètement
inondées ne sont plus que des marécages
vous au sinistre jonché d'arbres couchés
par la tempête
j'estime avoir deux années de bonnes
années de travail pour pouvoir récupérer
ce marais là aucun des trois mille
propriétaires forestiers n'a été épargné
pour eux c'est quinze ans de travail
fichu en l'air
quinze ans de revenus qui disparaissent
15 ans d'efforts pour réaménager le
marais qui échoue il faut donc tout
refaire repartir à zéro et commencer par
enlever tous ces voix qui pourrissent
dans 150 km de canaux il faut savoir
nous avons quand même quelques moyens
mécaniques à part avec l'aide des pelles
hydrauliques quand même pour extraire
tous ces gros boîte dans les canaux de
temps les cons surtout les données sur
steam en priorité à certaines congères
justement pour relancer l'exploitation
jamais de mémoire de maréchaux on avait
connu un tel désastre
le 25 juillet 83 une tornade avait bien
tout emporté sur son passage mais pas
avec une telle violence
on reconnaît tout le marais comment la
chaîne une semaine c'est dommage c'est
tout à refaire si tout en replanter et
ainsi de suite
il faut donc mettre en place un
véritable plan de bataille pour tenter
de redonner vie au marais mais ce sera
long très long et ça coûtera cher
peut-être ce ne sont pas trois millions
4 millions c'est plusieurs millions de
francs ça c'est sûr et pour les
riverains c'est le calme plat après la
tempête les promeneurs eux reviennent
silencieux des deux là point de vue
publié il ya du décor et encore il y en
aura encore s'il y avait encore des
coups de vent en importe
dans le marais on fera tout pour sauver
la venise verte pour que les peupliers
renaissent et que les touristes en
barque à nouveau sur les plates à la
découverte d'un paysage qui fait vivre
toute une région